credit recovery programs are on the rise
these programs let high-school students
who have fallen behind make up credits
needed to graduate without retaking the
original course as they've spread so
have scandals where schools use lacks
credit recovery programs to boost grad
rates so what policies the school
district have to ensure credit recovery
matches their academic standards we
surveyed 200 to find out turns out
district policies prioritize flexibility
with minimal quality control most
programs are available online all year
to all students Plus most let students
pretest out of lessons with no minimum
seat time and no school administered
exams schools face obvious pressure to
raise grad rates which is why school
districts need policies that answer the
question how will you ensure rigor in
your credit recovery programs when
districts have no good answer students
suffering to truly help struggling
students districts need to craft
policies that prioritize rigor or risk
being in the headline for the next
credit recovery scandal should credit
recovery courses be just as rigorous as
standard courses let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI